why is Gordon Ryan so good
so we're looking at you've trained a lot
of special athletes you're a special
human being yourself
I could just look at human history
there's a lot of
not a lot there's some special humans it
seems like Gordon Ryan is one of them I
I totally agree with that can you try to
like dissect that's what I meant when I
see a guy I had many students but only
one golden Ryan like I've taught many
many people but they don't all have his
skill level so there's an obvious
elephants in the room here okay what
distinguishes him from from other
athletes
great question I'll try and give an
answer
more than anyone else that I've ever
toured he has a memory
for things that were taught to him
he has an ability to recall information
that is extraordinary compared with
other people in the room so that's
definitely a big part of it
secondly he has a pride in technique and
Technical prowess
that will not allow him to settle for
anything less than Perfection and he
will hate himself when there is
imperfection
so there is a love of excellence and a
hatred of anything less than than
excellence
he has
an ability
to pull the trigger
when opportunity arises
which is truly extraordinary
many people know what to do but when the
moment comes
they back off
and they'll doubt themselves
if Gordon sees the opportunity the
trigger pulls every time
so again just just link on that
absolutely there's a few times where he
gets a little bit of an advantage and he
just chases it to get a big like uh with
Andre gaval you know you get it's like
uh there's a dance and you get one step
ahead and he's able to chase that you
know get a little glimmer of the back
and he's able to chase that all the way
to back control so that that is that
kind of the trigger that you're
referring to yes it runs deeper than
that too it's the idea is that good
athletes are greedy athletes
okay when they see a small opportunity
they try and get a as big a bite of it
as possible so that the manager that we
always have in training if you can see
the bag you can take the back and if
Gordon sees an inch of your back
you know that's the duration he's going
to be going if your far shoulder is
within an inch of the floor he's going
to be mounting you uh if your shoulder
comes off the floor he'll be on your
back on the other side
um he's a maximalist with opportunity
he's not satisfied with oh let me get a
good enough outcome it's like I want the
maximal outcome so when you combine all
these things together an ability to
recall information
which is just
far superior to anyone else I've ever
coached
an ability to
work in the training room towards not
just good technique but excellent
technique
the conference to pull the trigger
whenever the opportunity arises a
maximalist mindset where
It's never enough to have a good enough
outcome it's always got to be the best
possible outcome
and
The Fifth Element which I believe is
very very important
is
extraordinary depth
in his technical prowess
in particular with regards his defensive
Acumen everyone looks at Gordon and
focuses on his offensive prowess because
they see him dominate other athletes
but what they don't see is what I see
every day in the gym where he works from
impossibly Bad defensive positions
someone locked in on a full heel hook
on his body on a full Judy guitar me
Amber
in a complete pin mounted with Gordon's
two arms stretched out over his head in
what looks like a hopeless position
and Gordon will work in these positions
and of course because it's such a bad
position sometimes you'll have to tap
but he just works so relentlessly in
these bad positions that when he steps
on stage
he say
if this guy got the worst possible
position on me there's nothing he could
do with it and within 30 seconds I could
turn it around on him and win this match
um that gives his game
an overall breadth and depth which is
very very hard to deal with it means
there's no obvious weak point where you
can just say okay I'm going to attack
him here and use this strategy to to
beat them
um
and that goes back to uh his confidence
that
the reason why most people lack
confidence is they fear about bad
outcomes okay if if you're a strong
um guard player
you've got an excellent guide but you're
terrified of leg logs and your opponent
has strong leg logs you will shut down
your own guard
and won't play as freely and well as you
normally do because you're afraid of the
leg lock danger you'll pull your feet in
You'll Play a very
conservative guard game
but if you had extremely adept
leg lock defense then you just play with
all the uh the confidence you normally
do from from guard position
um Gordon puts himself in that situation
he's so defensively sound
that it translates into his offensive
confidence